Bonjour à tous, aujourd’hui on va parler
d’un argument climato-sceptique qu’on
entend assez régulièrement : l’effet de
serre serait «saturé». C’est-à-dire
que, supposément, l’effet de serre serait
déjà à son maximum.
Et donc on pourrait bien ajouter autant de
CO2 qu’on veut dans l’atmosphère, ça
ne provoquerait pas plus de réchauffement
qu’il n’y en a déjà actuellement.
Cet argument, il est intéressant, parce qu’on
va voir qu’il repose sur un raisonnement
physique assez convaincant.
L’argument n’est pas correct, évidemment,
mais pour voir pourquoi, il va falloir comprendre
comment fonctionne vraiment l’effet de serre
dans l’atmosphère.
Soyons clairs, mon but avec cette vidéo n’est
pas de convaincre les climato-sceptiques.
Ils ont décidé de ne pas croire les milliers
de scientifiques qui travaillent sur la question,
je ne vois pas pourquoi ils me croiraient
moi.
Non l’idée c’est de m’adresser à vous,
et d’utiliser ce prétexte pour parler de
phénomènes physiques intéressants et importants.
Et on va découvrir que ce mécanisme de l’effet
de serre porte plutôt mal son nom, et est
en fait assez différent de ce qu’on imagine
au premier abord, quand on fait la comparaison
avec une serre.
Et j’avoue que moi-même j’avais pas vraiment
tout compris au début.
[jingle]
Commençons avec le Soleil.
C’est lui qui fournit à la Terre l’immense
majorité de son énergie, et il le fait au
moyen du rayonnement.
Vous savez peut-être qu’il y a principalement
3 modes de transmission de la chaleur : la
conduction, qui fonctionne par contact, la
convection, quand on a un fluide dont les
mouvements transportent la chaleur, et en
enfin le rayonnement électromagnétique.
Entre le Soleil et la Terre, il y a l’espace
qui est essentiellement vide, donc il n’y
a que le rayonnement.
Vous savez peut-être que le Soleil émet
sa lumière dans une certaine plage de longueurs
d’onde, et qu’on peut tracer une courbe
qui nous montre l’intensité du rayonnement
émis en fonction des longueurs d’onde.
[SPECTRE SOLEIL : C’est ce qu’on appelle
le spectre du Soleil.
Au centre ici on a la lumière visible, entre
0,4 et 0,8 microns de longueur d’onde.
Avant les ultra-violets, avec des longueurs
d’onde plus courtes, et après les infrarouges.
La forme de cette courbe, elle ne vient pas
de nulle part.
Elle suit une loi physique universelle qu’on
appelle la loi de Planck, et qui ne dépend
que de la température de surface.
Pour le Soleil, c’est environ 5800 Kelvins,
soit un peu plus de 6000°C.
Mais si le soleil était un peu plus froid
ou un plus chaud, disons plus ou moins 200
degrés, la courbe serait légèrement différente.
Bien, ce spectre représente donc l’intensité
du rayonnement du Soleil pour chaque longueur
d’onde.
Maintenant si on veut connaitre l’ensemble
de la puissance lumineuse que le Soleil rayonne,
eh il faut additionner tout ça.
Mathématiquement, ça revient à regarder
l’aire totale sous la courbe.
Pour les intimes, ça s’appelle faire une
intégrale, et ici, dans le cas du Soleil,
on trouve une puissance cumulée d’environ
63 MW par m2.
Ca veut dire qu’un panneau d’1 mètre
carré placé pile à la surface du soleil
recevrait environ 63MW de puissance rayonnée.]
Evidemment la Terre est heureusement située
assez loin du Soleil, et nous on reçoit beaucoup
moins que ça.
Si on ne compte pas le rayonnement qui est
directement réfléchi par la surface, ou
les nuages, la Terre absorbe 240W de rayonnement
solaire par m2.
Bien sûr c’est une valeur moyenne : ça
dépend évidemment du moment, de la latitude,
etc.
Retenez bien ce chiffre : 240W/m2, c’est
le flux d’énergie en provenance du Soleil
que la Terre absorbe, sur l’ensemble des
longueurs d’ondes du spectre.
Et c’est comme ça que le Soleil chauffe
la Terre.
Sauf que si il n’y avait que ça, juste
de l’apport de chaleur en provenance Soleil,
eh bien la Terre accumulerait de l’énergie,
se réchaufferait en permanence et indéfiniment,
et ça fait longtemps qu’elle aurait fondu.
Heureusement, la Terre a un moyen d’évacuer
la chaleur en retour, et c’est également
via du rayonnement.
La Terre émet aussi en permanence un rayonnement
électromagnétique vers l’espace, et comme
pour le Soleil, ce rayonnement a un certain
spectre.
Et c’est ce spectre qui va nous intéresser
car c’est lui qui va gouverner la façon
dont la Terre évacue l’énergie.
[SATELLITE Et là ce qui est important, c’est
vraiment ce qui est émis vers l’espace.
On sait qu’on a la Terre, l’atmosphère,
qu’il va se passer des trucs là-dedans
avec le rayonnement.
Mais nous, tout ce qui nous intéresse à
la fin, c’est ce qui sort au sommet de l’atmosphère.
Imaginez qu’on se place au dessus avec un
satellite, et qu’on mesure tout le rayonnement
qui s’échappe en moyenne de la Terre.
Voilà c’est ça qu’on veut être capable
de quantifier pour comprendre comment la Terre
évacue l’énergie.]
Comment on estime ce spectre de rayonnement
vu depuis l’espace ? Pour commencer doucement,
on va faire un truc simple et un peu bizarre,
on va d’abord supposer qu’il n’y a pas
d’effet de serre.
On va garder toutes les autres caractéristiques
de la Terre, l’océan, les nuages, etc.
Mais on va juste mentalement éteindre l’effet
de serre.
[SATELLITE S’il n’y a pas d’effet de
serre, le rayonnement que la Terre évacue
vers l’espace est exactement celui qu’elle
émet depuis sa surface.
Le rayonnement traverse l’atmosphère sans
être affecté.
Donc pour savoir ce qui s’échappe, il nous
suffit de connaître le spectre du rayonnement
émis par la surface de la Terre.]
Et là c’est plutôt simple, la surface
de la Terre est comme la surface du Soleil,
elle émet un rayonnement de Planck, qui est
lié à sa température.
[SPECTRE TERRE : Voici à quoi il ressemble.
A première vue la forme du spectre semble
très similaire à ce qu’on avait pour le
Soleil, mais il y a une première grosse différence,
ce sont les longueurs d’onde.
Regardez ici, j’ai gradué jusqu’à 50
microns sur l’axe des abscisses, et l’essentiel
de l’émission se fait entre 5 et 30.
Pour le soleil, le gros de l’émission se
faisait en-dessous de 2 microns, et notamment
dans la partie visible qui est entre 0,4 et
0,8.
Je vous la remets pour visualiser.
Si c’est si différent, c’est parce que
la température de surface de la Terre est
bien plus basse que celle du Soleil ! Et donc
la Terre émet du rayonnement dans ce qu’on
appelle les infrarouges lointains.
Si je trace le spectre du Soleil avec le même
axe des abscisses, on voit que les longueurs
d’onde de rayonnement de la Terre et du
Soleil sont presque complètement séparées.]
L’autre différence entre la surface de
la Terre et celle du Soleil, du fait de leur
énorme différence de température, c’est
que l’intensité totale du rayonnement est
beaucoup plus faible.
Vous vous souvenez, on l’obtenait en sommant
toutes les longueurs d’onde, c’est-à-dire
en calculant l’aire sous la courbe.
[SPECTRE TERRE : Pour le Soleil ça faisait
63 MW/m2.
Pour la Terre, ça va faire beaucoup moins,
et encore heureux, la Terre n’est pas une
étoile.
Ça a pas l’air comme ça sur mes deux courbes
car j’ai utilisé des échelles très différentes
en ordonnées, mais dans en cumulant l’énergie
totale émise par la surface de la Terre,
on va plutôt être entre 200 et 400W/m2.]
Je reste volontairement assez vague sur la
fourchette, car on va justement devoir préciser
ça.
On l’a dit, la Terre absorbe 240W/m2 en
provenance du Soleil.
Et pour faire le bilan, ce qui nous intéresse
c’est de savoir exactement entre contrepartie
combien elle re-rayonne vers l’espace.
[PUISSANCE TERRE : La forme précise du spectre
de la Terre dépend de la température moyenne
de sa surface.
Je vous mets plusieurs de ces spectres, pour
des températures entre -40 et +40°C Celsius.
On voit que plus la température est élevée,
plus la surface sous la courbe est grande,
et donc la puissance totale rayonnée est
importante.
Et comme c’est pas très simple de comparer
visuellement ces surfaces, ici je vous mets
le total de puissance correspondant pour chacune
de ces courbes.
On voit que suivant la température de surface,
ça se balade entre 150 et plus de 500 W/m2.
Et il faut bien comprendre que ces différentes
valeurs de puissance totale correspondent
aux différentes aires des surfaces sous les
courbes.
Si je me concentre par exemple sur les spectres
pour 0°C et 5°C, elles correspondent respectivement
à 315W et 339W, ça fait 24W de différence,
et ces 24 Watts sont vraiment la surface de
la petite bande entre les deux spectres, que
j’ai coloriée en jaune.
Cette notion de comparer des surfaces sous
les spectres, et d’en déduire des différences
de puissance rayonnée, on va la retrouver
tout le long de nos explications.]
Voilà, on sait quantifier l’énergie perdue
par la Terre, en fonction de sa température
de surface, dans l’hypothèse où l’effet
de serre a magiquement disparu.
Maintenant, on a dit que le Soleil nous fournissait
240W/m2 en moyenne.
Si on veut que la Terre soit à l’équilibre,
qu’elle reçoive autant d’énergie qu’elle
en émet, il faut qu’elle rayonne aussi
en retour 240W/m2.
[PUISSANCE TERRE : Et on peut voir sur la
courbe que ça correspondrait à une température
de surface d’environ -18°Celsius.
-18°C, ce serait la température qu’aurait
la Terre à l’équilibre, si on éteignait
juste l’effet de serre mais en gardant tout
le reste.
Et les 240W correspondant c’est l’aire
sous la courbe du spectre de Planck qu’on
obtient à -18°C.]
Sans effet de serre, la Terre serait à l’équilibre
thermique à -18°C.
Et surtout le truc se régulerait tout seul.
[PUISSANCE TERRE : Si la Terre était plus
froide, disons -25°C, le total rayonné serait
seulement de 215W/m2, moins que ce qu’elle
reçoit du soleil.
Donc il y aurait 25W/m2 de déséquilibre.
Ce déséquilibre, c’est qu’on appelle
le forçage radiatif, le bonus de puissance
qu’on reçoit du fait de ne pas être à
la température d’équilibre.
Du fait de ces 25W/m2 de forçage radiatif,
la Terre se réchaufferait et sa température
augmenterait, jusqu’à atteindre l’équilibre
à -18°C.
A l’inverse, si la Terre était plus chaude
que cet équilibre, elle rayonnerait plus
que 240W/m2, elle perdrait de l’énergie,
se refroidirait et tendrait aussi vers -18°C.]
Bien je vous rappelle que tout ça c’était
sans effet de serre, dans le cas où le rayonnement
émis à la surface traverse complètement
l’atmosphère et s’échappe dans l’espace.
Maintenant, on va rallumer l’effet de serre.
Pour des raisons que je vais vous expliquer
dans la suite, on va voir que l’impact de
l’effet de serre est de diminuer la capacité
de la Terre à évacuer de l’énergie.
[PUISSANCE TERRE : A cause de l’effet de
serre, la courbe en rouge est remplacée par
quelque chose qui ressemble à la courbe en
vert.
A température équivalente, l’énergie
s’évacue moins bien.
Notamment, on voit maintenant que pour évacuer
240W/m2, la Terre doit avoir une température
de surface de 288K, environ 15°C.
En rallumant l’effet de serre, on a diminué
la capacité de la Terre à évacuer la chaleur,
et donc on a déplacé le point d’équilibre
de plus de 30°.
Et c’est une bonne manière de se représenter
ce que fait l’effet de serre : une perte
de capacité d’évacuation d’énergie,
et donc un déplacement de l’équilibre
vers des températures plus chaudes.]
Et donc l’effet de serre c’est puissant
et c’est indispensable à une bonne partie
de la vie telle qu’on la connait, puisque
c’est ce qui permet qu’il fasse en moyenne
15°C sur Terre plutôt que -18°C.
Bien, notre but dans la suite ça va donc
être de comprendre le mécanisme détaillé
qui provoque cette moins bonne évacuation
de la chaleur par la Terre.
Mais avant ça revenons sur l’appellation
«effet de serre». C’est une analogie
assez ancienne qu’on doit d’ailleurs au
scientifique français Fourier au XIXe siècle.
[SERRE Imaginez une serre dont j’aurais
retiré toutes les vitres, il ne reste que
le cadre métallique.
Ce qu’il y à l’intérieur reçoit la
chaleur du soleil, par rayonnement.
Et en retour cette chaleur sera perdue, notamment
par les mouvements de l’air, puisque j’ai
viré les vitres.
Maintenant si je remets les vitres, je limite
la capacité de la serre à évacuer sa chaleur,
il ne reste plus qu’un peu de conduction
et de rayonnement, je crée donc un déséquilibre
qui fait augmenter la température.
Mais vous voyez que c’est surtout une histoire
de supprimer la convection, pas vraiment de
rayonnement comme dans l’effet de serre
atmosphérique.
Donc l’analogie a ses limites.]
Bien alors revenons justement à la Terre
: pourquoi est-ce que les gaz à effet de
serre causent … ce qu’on appelle l’effet
de serre.
Eh bien vous le savez peut-être : c’est
parce qu’ils absorbent les rayonnements
infra-rouges, ou du moins certaines longueurs
d’onde dans les infrarouges.
Et pourquoi est-ce qu’ils absorbent ? Eh
bien parce que les excite.
[MOLECULE : Oui oui c’est vraiment comme
ça qu’on dit.
Les molécules comme le CO2 ou la vapeur d’eau
sont susceptibles d’absorber certains rayonnement
infrarouges qui correspondent à l’énergie
nécessaire pour les mettre dans des états
dits «excités».
Dans ces états, les molécules ont des mouvements
qui sont des sortes de torsion ou d’élongation
de leur structure.
Ce sont des mouvements qui n’existent pas
pour des molécules comme le dioxygène ou
le diazote, qui ne sont donc pas des gaz à
effet de serre.
Alors que le méthane, le CO2, la vapeur d’eau
ou le protoxyde d’azote en sont.]
L’absorption de rayonnement infrarouge se
fait pour chaque molécule dans des plages
de longueurs d’ondes spécifiques, qui correspondent
aux énergies qui les mettent dans ces états
excités.
On appelle ça les bandes d’absorption.
Et c’est pour ça que les gaz à effet de
serre absorbent certains rayonnements, mais
en laissent passer d’autres.
[SPECTRE TERRE Là où c’est pas de bol,
c’est qu’ils n’absorbent pas beaucoup
les rayonnements visibles, ceux que nous envoie
le Soleil, mais ils absorbent pas mal dans
les longueurs d’onde des infrarouges émis
par la Terre.
Ils laissent passer la chaleur entrante, mais
pas la chaleur sortante ! Et c’est ce qui
va limiter la capacité de la Terre à évacuer
son énergie.]
Comme la Terre reçoit en moyenne 240W/m2
de la part du Soleil, on l’a dit, pour être
à l’équilibre, elle doit évacuer aussi
240 W/m2.
Mais est-ce le cas ?
[SATELLITE Pour bien l’analyser en présence
d’effet de serre, il faut bien faire cette
fois la distinction entre le spectre émis
à la surface de la Terre, et celui qu’on
verrait avec un satellite depuis le sommet
de l’atmosphère.
C’est lui qui nous intéresse car c’est
celui-là qui nous dit ce que la Terre arrive
à évacuer vers l’espace.]
Distinguons donc bien les deux spectres : celui
émis par la surface de la Terre, et ce qui
s’échappe au sommet de l’atmosphère,
qu’on peut mesurer en principe avec un satellite.
[TROU SPECTRE Sans effet de serre, le spectre
émis par la surface est exactement celui
qui sort au sommet de l’atmosphère, donc
s’il y a un total de 240W/m2 émis à la
surface, ce sera le même qui s’évacue.
C’est l’équilibre.
Maintenant si on rallume soudainement l’effet
de serre, et si les gaz à effet de serre
empêchent la sortie du rayonnement dans certaines
bandes d’infrarouges, ça va créer comme
un trou dans le spectre émis vers l’espace.
Qui dit trou dans le spectre, dit une aire
sous la courbe plus faible, et donc moins
d’énergie évacuée, moins en tout cas
que les 240 qu’on reçoit du Soleil.
Ca crée donc un déséquilibre qui réchauffe
la Terre.
La température de surface va alors augmenter,
le spectre émis va légèrement enfler jusqu’à
ce que le total de ce qui sort atteigne à
nouveau les 240W/m2 nécessaires, et que l’équilibre
soit retrouvé.]
Avec cette visualisation comme un trou dans
le spectre, on comprend le mécanisme : les
gaz à effet de serre bloquent une partie
du rayonnement sortant, la Terre évacue moins
bien sa chaleur, et donc se réchauffe pour
retrouver l’équilibre.
Limpide, non ?
Sauf que vous voyez que ça a une limite : si
dans une certaine bande de longueur d’onde
tout est absorbé, le trou serait maximal,
et dans ce cas ça ne pourrait plus empirer.
Eh bien, on dirait que c’est ce qu’il
se passe avec le CO2 !
[BANDES CO2 Regardons de plus prêt ses bandes
d’absorption.
Vous les voyez schématisées ici, ça représente
en gros l’intensité de l’absorption du
CO2, en fonction de la longueur d’onde,
pour une pression et une température donnée.
La principale bande est autour de 15 microns.]
Maintenant si on prend le rayonnement émis
par la surface de la Terre autour de ces longueurs
d’onde, on peut se demander, quel fraction
de ce rayonnement est actuellement absorbée
par le CO2 présent dans l’atmosphère.
Et la réponse est : 100%.
Et non seulement c’est 100%, mais c’est
assez violent, c’est même totalement absorbé
dans les premiers dizaines de mètres.
Si vous preniez un laser méga-puissant qui
tire dans l’infrarouge autour de 15 microns,
le rayon n’irait pas bien haut avant d’être
complètement absorbé par l’atmosphère.
L’atmosphère de la Terre absorbe déjà
à mort dans les bandes d’absorption du
CO2.
Donc on peut bien doubler ou tripler la concentration
de CO2 dans l’atmosphère, il ne va pas
absorber plus que ce qu’il absorbe déjà,
vu qu’il absorbe déjà tout.
Pour prendre une image, si vous avez une vitre
complètement noire épaisse de 5cm qui ne
laisse pas passer la lumière, vous pouvez
bien la faire de 10 ou 20cm d’épaisseur
ça changera rien.
L’impact du CO2 sur l’effet de serre c’est
pareil, il est saturé, il ne pourra pas être
plus fort que ce qu’il n’est.
Et donc il n’y a pas de problème de réchauffement
climatique…à moins que…
C’est quand même bizarre parce l’argument
a l’air assez convaincant.
Et en même temps les scientifiques du climat,
qui savent quand même de quoi ils parlent,
nous disent que : si par exemple on double
la concentration de CO2 dans l’atmosphère,
on va créer un déséquilibre, un forçage
radiatif, d’au moins 3W/m2, provoquant un
réchauffement de quelques degrés.
Ils sont bêtes les climatologues, ils ont
pas vu que c’était saturé ?
Eh bien malheureusement, cet argument de la
saturation est incorrect.
Mais il est quand même intéressant, on va
voir pourquoi.
Et d’ailleurs il ne date pas d’hier, il
avait même été formulé pour la première
fois en 1901.
[ARRHENIUS Il faut savoir que dès 1896, le
chimiste suédois Svante Arrhenius avait déjà
cherché à quantifier l’impact du taux
de CO2 atmosphérique sur le réchauffement.
Avant qu’un autre suédois, Anders Angström
ne convainque la communauté scientifique
que ce que disait Arrhenius était incorrect,
puisque l’atmosphère absorbait déjà tout
ce qu’elle pouvait, dans les bandes d’absorption
du CO2.
Et donc que l’effet de serre existait bien
mais était saturé.]
Sauf qu’Arrhenius et Angström, il y a plus
d’un siècle, ne savaient pas tout ce qu’on
sait aujourd’hui de la physique de l’atmosphère
et du rayonnement.
Alors voyons ça ensemble.
[jingle]
Admettons que l’effet de serre soit saturé
pour le CO2.
[TROU Sa principale bande d’absorption est
autour de 15 microns.
Si on en croit l’argument, tout est absorbé
par l’atmosphère dans cette bande, donc
si on observait depuis l’espace le rayonnement
émis par la Terre, on devrait avoir un trou
complet, rien qui ne passe.
Mais en fait ça n’est pas ce qu’on voit
! Il se trouve qu’on peut avec des satellites
faire des mesures du rayonnement émis par
la Terre, notamment dans l’infrarouge, et
voici ce qu’on observe.
La bande d’absorption à 15 microns est
ici, et vous voyez qu’effectivement le spectre
est creusé à cet endroit là, mais pas du
tout jusqu’au bout, il reste du rayonnement
dans cette bande qui s’échappe du sommet
de l’atmosphère.]
Comment se fait-il que, vu depuis l’espace
avec un satellite, la Terre émette du rayonnement
à 15 microns alors qu’on l’a vu juste
avant, il n’y a aucun doute là-dessus,
l’atmosphère absorbe complètement dans
cette bande.
Eh bien c’est parce que penser que l’atmosphère
ne fait que absorber, c’est une vision erronée.
Un simple trou dans le spectre, c’est ce
qu’on aurait à la limite si l’atmosphère
agissait comme un miroir aux infrarouges.
Qu’elle les renvoie vers la Terre, un peu
comme ce que fait une couverture de survie.
Mais non, l’atmosphère absorbe, et qui
dit absorption dit … émission.
On l’a dit tout à l’heure, tous les corps
rayonnent, avec un spectre qui dépend de
leur température, c'est la loi de Planck.
Et elle s'applique au Soleil, à la surface
de la Terre, mais aussi aux gaz de l’atmosphère.
Et la capacité à rayonner d’un gaz est
la même que sa capacité à absorber.
Ce sont deux processus symétriques au niveau
microscopique.
Plus un gaz absorbe à une certaine longueur
d'onde, plus il va pouvoir émettre à cette
longueur d'onde.
Et donc dans l’atmosphère, les gaz à effet
de serre comme le CO2 ,non seulement absorbent
le rayonnement infrarouge, mais il vont également
en émettre, en rayonner, en suivant la loi
de Planck.
Donc pour bien saisir ce qu’il se passe
sur l'ensemble de l'atmosphère, il faut raisonner
par couches successives.
[COUCHE Prenons une longueur d’onde donnée,
disons autour de 15 microns, et par exemple
les dix premiers mètres de l’atmosphère
à partir du sol.
En traversant cette couche, une partie du
rayonnement émis par la Terre va être absorbée,
et l'autre partie va être transmise, et aller
vers la couche supérieure.
Mais la première couche va elle-même émettre
du rayonnement, vers le haut et vers le bas.
La couche située juste au-dessus verra donc
arriver à la fois le rayonnement transmis
par la précédente, auquel s'ajoute celui
émis.
Et on recommence le raisonnement dans cette
deuxième couche.
Sur ce total qui arrive, une partie sera transmise,
une partie absorbée, et il y aura de l’émission
en plus.
Et ainsi de suite.]
Et on peut traiter ainsi toutes les couches
de l’atmosphère, les unes après les autres.
Heureusement, ça ne dure pas indéfiniment,
puisque l’air se raréfie quand on monte
en altitude, donc il y a de moins en moins
de molécules de CO2, de moins en moins d’absorption
et de plus en plus de transmission, jusqu’à
ce que le rayonnement s’échappe complètement
vers l’espace.
Et vous voyez avec ce raisonnement que même
si l’atmosphère absorbe à fond une certaine
longueur d’onde dans les couches inférieures,
elle émettra quand même dans cette longueur
d’onde, à partir des couches supérieures,
et donc on verra quand même du rayonnement
à cette longueur d’onde s’échapper vers
l’espace.
Pour l’instant j’explique les phénomènes,
mais ce qu’on aimerait c’est pouvoir quantifier
précisément tout ça.
Pour ça, on peut faire une petite simulation
numérique qui permet de modéliser la transmission,
l’absorption et l’émission dans chaque
couche de l’atmosphère, et pour chaque
longueur d’onde.
J’ai fait un petit code très simplifié
en Python, je le mettrai sur Github pour ceux
que ça intéresse.
Bien sûr l’idée n’est pas de reproduire
de façon fidèle les vrais calculs des chercheurs
du domaine, mais de comprendre les principes
généraux, et de voir si on retrouve les
bons ordres de grandeur.
C’est ce qu’on appelle parfois faire un
modèle-jouet.
[MODELE Voici comment la simulation fonctionne.
En entrée j’ai besoin de connaitre les
bandes d’absorption des gaz à effet de
serre.
Il y en a plusieurs, CO2, H2O, CH4, etc. et
ils ont tous plein de bandes d'absorption,
qui ont une forme assez complexe.
Je vais donc faire une très grosse simplification
: considérer qu’il n’y a que le CO2,
ne regarder que sa bande à 15 microns, la
principale, et la modéliser par une forme
approchée.
On va aussi avoir besoin d’une description
de l’atmosphère, c’est-à-dire d’une
courbe qui donne la pression et la quantité
de molécules en fonction de l’altitude.
C’est quelque chose qui est bien connu,
je vais prendre ce qu’on appelle un profil
hydrostatique.
Et ensuite, on y va : dans chaque couche,
je calcule le coefficient d’absorption,
qui est donc aussi le coefficient d’émission.
Il va bien sûr dépendre de la quantité
de CO2 présente dans la couche.
On considère qu’il y a un certain % de
CO2, qu’il est le même partout, et comme
il y a de moins en moins d’air en altitude,
il y a de moins en moins de molécules de
CO2.
Et je fais tourner mon modèle, couche par
couche, pour calculer ce qui entre dans chaque
couche, ce qui est absorbé, transmis, et
émis.
Je le fais pour chaque longueur d’onde,
ça se parallélise bien, et on va pouvoir
regarder le résultat.
Et ce résultat, ce sera le spectre vu depuis
l’espace, dont je vous rappelle qu’il
nous permet de connaitre l’énergie totale
dont la Terre se débarrasse, en regardant
l'aire sous la courbe.]
Il me manque un petit ingrédient toutefois.
Je vous ai dit que chaque couche de l’atmosphère
émettait du rayonnement selon la loi de Planck.
Or la loi de Planck fait intervenir la température,
donc pour ça il nous faut la température
de chaque couche de l’atmosphère.
Commençons par un modèle simple dans lequel
l’atmosphère est comme la surface de la
Terre, à 15°C.
[ISOTHERME Je fais tourner mon modèle.
S’il n’y avait pas de gaz à effet de
serre le spectre au sommet de l'atmosphère
serait celui-ci, et là quand je mets les
gaz à effet de serre, voici ce que j’ai
: … ah, ben en fait c’est exactement le
même spectre.
Comment ça se fait ? L’atmosphère absorbe
à fond dans la bande de 15 microns, et il
en ressort pourtant tout autant en haut de
l’atmosphère ?]
Eh bien en fait tout cela est logique.
La Terre est à 15°C, elle émet du rayonnement.
L’atmosphère l’absorbe en partie et le
ré-émet ensuite.
Et comme on a supposé que l’atmosphère
était aussi à 15°C, elle le ré-émet exactement
de la même manière.
Avec une atmosphère à température constante
identique à celle de la surface, il n’y
a aucun impact des gaz à effet de serre.
L’émission et l’absorption des infrarouges
sont symétriques.
Le spectre vu depuis l’espace sera le même
qu’à la surface.
La seule différence c’est que dans
les bandes d’absorption, ce rayonnement
vu de l’espace sera originaire des couches
plus élevées de l’atmosphère, au lieu
d’être en provenance directe de la surface
de la Terre.
Ca veut dire que la grosse différence entre
pas de gaz à effet de serre et présence
de gaz à effet de serre, c'est la provenance
du rayonnement qui atteint l’espace.
Imaginons que je sois capable d'interroger
un à un les photons qui ressortent au sommet
de l’atmosphère.
S’il n'y a pas d'effet de serre, les photons
me diraient tous qu'ils arrivent de la surface.
[INTERROGATION Mais avec l'effet de serre,
ce serait différent.
Hors des bandes d’absorption, les photons
seraient aussi en provenance de la surface,
mais dans les bandes d’absorption, les photons
me diraient qu’ils ont été émis par certaines
couches de l’atmosphère.
On peut même quantifier ça plus précisément,
et dans la bande du CO2 à 15 microns, on
trouverait que la plupart du rayonnement a
été émis entre 10 et 20km d’altitude.]
Maintenant revenons sur notre hypothèse concernant
la température de l’atmosphère.
Je vous ai dit que j'avais supposé une atmosphère
à température constante, c’est évidemment
pas le cas pour la nôtre.
Utilisons plutôt un vrai profil de température.
[ATMOSPHERE Dans la couche inférieure, qu'on
appelle la troposphère, la température chute
d'environ 6,5 degré par kilomètre.
Et à environ 11km d'altitude, on arrive dans
une zone appelée la tropopause où la température
devient essentiellement constante, environ
-55°C, soit autour de 217K.]
J'injecte ce profil de température dans mon
code, et je l'utilise pour la loi de Planck,
et donc le rayonnement de chacune des couches.
[PROFIL SIMPLE Et là j'observe dans le spectre
vu de l’espace qu’il y a maintenant un
trou autour de la bande des 15 microns.
Mais un trou qui ne va pas jusque tout en
bas, il reste du rayonnement émis vers l’espace
dans cette plage de longueur d’onde.
Et on peut comprendre exactement la forme
de ce trou.
Je vous ai dit que dans cette bande autour
de 15 microns, les photons qui atteignaient
l'espace provenaient principalement des altitudes
situées entre 10 et 20km.
Or on l'a dit, cela correspond à cette zone
de l’atmosphère appelée la tropopause,
où la température est essentiellement constante,
autour de 217K.
Donc les rayonnements qui sont là ont été
émis à la température de 217K, et ça se
voit d'ailleurs très bien parce qu'on peut
tracer un spectre de Planck à 217K, et voir
que ça l'épouse parfaitement.
Et grâce à ça, on comprend vraiment comment
marche l'effet de serre atmosphérique : l'absorption
n'élimine pas les rayonnement infrarouges
dont se débarrasse la Terre, mais il les
fait parvenir de zones de l'atmosphère plus
froides, et donc moins efficaces pour rayonner.]
Alors souvenez vous bien que je suis sur un
modèle jouet ultra simplifié ! Juste le
CO2, une seule bande d’absorption.
Mais qualitativement on comprend bien ce qui
se passe.
Le trou qu'on voit dans le spectre vu depuis
l’espace n'est pas directement un effet
de l'absorption en soi, mais provient d’un
rayonnement ré-émis depuis des couches plus
froides de l’atmosphère, et donc moins
intense.
[OBSERVATIONS Et ce qu'on voit est bien raccord
avec les observations satellite, ici c'est
bien un bout de spectre de Planck à 217K
environ.
Et pour les parties que l’on voit là, elles
correspondent à du rayonnement émis majoritairement
dans la troposphère, donc entre la température
de la surface et celle de la tropopause.]
Parfois pour schématiser, on va parler d’altitude
d’émission, en faisant comme si tous les
rayonnements d’une certaine longueur d’onde
provenaient d’une altitude spécifique de
l’atmosphère.
Mais c’est une simplification, il faut s’imaginer
que c’est distribué autour d’une sorte
d’altitude moyenne.
Bien, maintenant qu’on a bien compris comment
fonctionne l’effet de serre atmosphérique,
on va pouvoir se poser la question de ce qu’il
se passe si on continue de rejeter du CO2
dans l’atmosphère.
La référence qu’on prend généralement,
c’est le taux de CO2 à l’aire pré-industrielle,
environ 280ppm.
280ppm, parties par millions, ça fait 0,028%
de CO2.
[COMPARAISON Si je mets cette valeur dans
le modèle, j’obtiens donc cette courbe
là, en vert.
Maintenant si je double cette valeur, à 560ppm,
avec ma simulation j’obtiens ça.
Les courbes ont l’air très proches, mais
on voit une légère différence non pas au
centre de la bande, mais sur les côtés.
Or souvenez vous maintenant, quand on a des
spectres comme ça, l’ensemble de l’aire
sous la courbe ça représente la puissance
totale que la Terre rayonne et donc la chaleur
dont elle arrive à se débarrasser.
Et si on double le CO2, on passe d’une courbe
à l’autre et donc on ampute légèrement
cette capacité de refroidissement.
Alors oui, c’est pas grand chose, c’est
juste les petites surfaces qu’on a de chaque
côté.
Et on peut exprimer cette surface en puissance,
dans mon modèle simplifié, ça représente
environ 4.8W/m2.
Cette valeur, c’est le forçage radiatif
associé à un doublement du CO2 par rapport
aux valeurs préindustrielles.
En doublant le CO2, la Terre perd 4.8W/m2
de capacité de refroidissement, et donc son
équilibre thermique est rompu, et elle va
devoir se réchauffer pour retrouver l’équilibre.]
La valeur que je trouve avec mon modèle très
simplifié a le bon ordre de grandeur, mais
ça n’est pas non plus une valeur super-précise.
Les vraies simulations des scientifiques prennent
en compte tous les gaz à effet de serre,
toutes les bandes d’absorption, et des profils
d’atmosphère plus précis.
Mais la valeur actuellement retenue pour le
forçage radiatif associé à un doublement
du CO2, c’est 3.7W/m2.
Si vous voulez expérimenter plus précisément
avec un modèle plus riche que le mien, vous
pouvez utiliser le modèle MODTRAN, qui est
en accès libre sur le site de l’université
de Chicago.
Vous pouvez rentrer vos paramètres et voir
les spectres associés, le flux sortant total,
et estimer les forçages radiatifs en faisant
les différences entre deux scénarios.
[MODTRAN Un truc que vous verrez, c’est
que si vous allez vers des taux de CO2 suffisamment
élevés, on voit apparaitre un petit pic
dans le spectre en plein centre de la bande
à 15 microns.
Ce pic correspond à des longueurs d’ondes
où l’absorption est tellement forte que
l’altitude d’émission est déplacée
au-delà de 20km, dans une zone qui est la
stratosphère, où la température réaugmente
quand on monte.
Cela correspond à une émission plus chaude
que dans la tropopause et donc cela produit
ce petit pic dans le spectre qu’on retrouve
aussi sur les vraies observations satellite.]
Malheureusement ce pic est bien trop petit
pour compenser le forçage radiatif qu’on
a par ailleurs, mais il a au moins un avantage
sur le plan de la compréhension scientifique.
Puisque l’émission en plein coeur de la
bande a lieu dans la stratosphère, une prédiction
de ce modèle est que si la surface de la
Terre se réchauffe, en revanche la stratosphère
doit se refroidir légèrement.
L’article scientifique qui a fait ces calculs
pour la première fois a été publié très
tôt, en 1967, notamment par le scientifique
japonais Syukuro Manabe, qui a reçu le prix
Nobel de physique en 2021.
Et petit fun fact pour les habitués du RER
B, c’est précisément cet article dont
on peut voir les équations reproduites, avec
des fautes, sur les quais du RER à Gare du
Nord.
Bref, les modèles prédisent depuis longtemps
qu’à cause de l’augmentation de l’effet
de serre, la stratosphère doit se refroidir.
Et c’est effectivement quelque chose qu’on
observe depuis plusieurs décennies, et qui
valide notre compréhension du mécanisme
de l’effet de serre.
Il y a d’ailleurs eu une publication très
récente sur le sujet qui montre bien tout
cela.
En conclusion, on voit que le lien entre concentration
en gaz à effet de serre et forçage radiatif
est plutôt très bien compris, et repose
sur des phénomènes physiques qu’on maitrise
bien.
Sauf que pour avoir des estimations précises,
il faut faire un modèle complet avec tous
les gaz et toutes les bandes, pas comme le
mien.
Mais sur le plan fondamental, il n’y a pas
trop de débats, et les estimations varient
d’ailleurs assez peu depuis 30 ans au fur
et à mesure qu’on affine un peu plus les
modèles et les mesures des bandes d’absorption.
3 à 4 W/m2 pour un doublement du CO2, ça
semble être le tarif.
Une fois qu’on en est là, du point de vue
de la modélisation, on n’a fait que la
moitié du chemin.
Il faut ensuite pouvoir calculer l’impact
de ce forçage radiatif sur la température
à l’échelle mondiale, dans l’atmosphère,
dans les océans, en fonctions des différents
endroits de la planète et des différents
scénarios.
Pour cela on utilise une autre classe de modèles,
les modèles de circulation générale, qui
se basent sur les équations de la mécanique
des fluides, et qui pour le coup mobilisent
des puissances de calcul bien plus importantes.
Mais ça, ce sera pour un prochain épisode
!
Merci d’avoir suivi la vidéo, n’hésitez
pas à vous abonner si ça vous a plus, à
rejoindre le serveur Discord de Science étonnante
pour prolonger la discussion.
Un grand merci à Jacques Treiner et Jean-Louis
Dufresne, deux spécialistes de ces questions
qui ont écrit un très bon article sur le
sujet, et qui m’ont mis sur la voie pour
que j’arrive à créer mon propre petit
modèle numérique.
Abonnez vous si vous aimez ce contenu, et
moi je vous dis à très vite pour une nouvelle
vidéo.
A bientôt !